hello I'm Gavin dan we're the slow mo
guys and today we're looking at some
slow-mo clips from the internet let's
get started this is slo-mo water
balloons by legendary shots 87 million
views on Facebook everyone seen a
balloon of water yeah get drop-top
hopped and you never see it for this
long with your eyes so that's why it's
quite satisfying when they pop the
rubber is so much faster than the
gravity of the water so you want your
not would like it the shape of the
waters hanging in the air but in this
there's a lot of the balloon not popping
yeah equal is interesting equal is
interesting we've some very weird shapes
lots of ripples it's as if water had
incredible surface tension you end up
left with these really bizarre moments
entirely when this glove is like right
up the balloon it's almost like an
umbrella split-second moment in time but
here's the high speed we can see it for
ages
this video is nice and sharp a lot of
high speed cameras have an optical
low-pass filter which kind of softens it
I don't think this camera has one
because it looks very crisp kind of poor
dynamic range so it looks like it
doesn't know what they picked the right
frame rate which I assume is just like
we do the maximum frame rate at the
highest resolution if you do that then
it also means that you can go down from
there
always yeah they've also shot it square
I'm not sure if that was shot like that
or whether it's been cropped a lot of
the high speed cameras we used to use
actually have a square sensor and then
you can just crop to HD or if you want
to shoot a full square you basically got
the fastest Instagram camera how this
thing was something that this is
actually getting the balloons right
we've done it a few times to different
balloons and they've all got different
levels of strength sometimes they pop
sometimes they act differently yeah
we've shot stuff where we've tried to
pop a balloon like on your head or
something like that and it just wouldn't
go oh they'll pop while you're filling
them but then when you actually throw in
there for some reason bounce off it all
depends on just like the quality of the
rubber or how long they've been in a
drawer mostly the second most through
the second one it's probably just been
on the floor of the garage here this is
will bulletproof glass stop a 50 Cal
bullet by full mag
Richard Ryan mmmm we he's done a ton of
great high-speed of guns lots of guns a
stuff and you'll notice here that a lot
of his footage is really really wide
screen because on most high speed video
cameras if you lower the resolution you
gain frame rate and because the bullet
is always sort of left to right it takes
up very little of an HD frame you can
just lose the top and bottom and then he
actually does a very good job in the
Edit sliding that up and maybe showing
in student in again it's
so that the frame is filled this is
obviously slow enough to see a bullet
traveling through the air which is an
incredibly high frame rate but it also
just shows you how quickly got glass
cracks it's faster than the bullet seems
to be mmm when we shoot stuff with
bullets it's always good to have an
exposure time of at least 10
microseconds just so it's not a tol blur
because you can still shoot in slow-mo
and if you're sure speed isn't right
you'll have a ton of pictures of just a
very very blurred bullet to reduce
motion blur you have to increase the
shutter speed which drastically lowers
the amount of light you have which means
you have way less depth it's always
preferable to have the bullet sort of
going left to right as opposed to an
angle because it will be in focus the
whole time and usually the depth is you
know varies really really small he
shoots a ton of his stuff completely
solo sort of framing up on standing
objects and then shooting the gun
triggering the camera himself it's very
impressive
you just hold the bullet in place this
is tattooing in slow motion by
smartereveryday actually my favorite
YouTube channel Destin makes these
videos legend this is a great example of
showing something that everyone has seen
but in a completely different way with
any slow motion I think it's pretty
difficult to shoot especially with macro
you've got such a fine amount of focus
in slow motion you do a lot of light
because each exposure time is so small
getting the the focus is much more
difficult when you're in slow-mo and
doing macro at the same time you got
sort of millimetres of depth so Destin's
done a great job here of absolutely
nailing that focus yeah and not blinding
a primal delight
especially with the fact that the needle
is moving towards the camera you
wouldn't necessarily notice but you
wouldn't know is exactly how hard it is
to get that sort of footage you're
really seeing two levels down on stuff
the users can't see with your eye I mean
you see those with your eye and it's
almost like you're watching a blur like
you're watching a vibration it will get
tattooed every day but gives you a
completely new perspective on it which
is pretty cool I've always wanted a
tattoo but after seeing this video I'm
not sure I can take it
this is to slow motion lightning strikes
nature wants to get an excellent subject
for slow-mo lightning is very very very
fast suppose like third of the speed of
light like tend to the speed of light
coming down I think a third we actually
those because we recently film lightning
much faster than this clip actually up
to a hundred and three thousand frames a
second you can't necessarily see the
travel of the lightning in this clip but
you can see it lingering in the air long
enough to the point where it you can
tell it's lit in slow motion when the
event in high speed is is so short it's
very hard to find the clip if you're
shooting a hundred thousand frames a
second for five seconds your clip lasts
like point zero five of a second because
lightning is that fast it's very
difficult to find where it is so we
actually used something called image
based auto trigger which lets us know
the exact frame and it triggered a
camera itself on the frame filling so
you can very quickly see where it was
save it and move on to the next clip the
last thing you want is to miss good
lightning strikes because you're still
saving the previous one also means that
you don't have to trim the footage so
imagine if you're saving eight seconds
of footage just for one lightning strike
you don't have to then save the entire
thing yeah and wait for it to do that
and then carry on you can just you don't
to keep three million pictures of the
sky when only you know a couple of
thousand have lightning in them this is
WTF flat ground tricks 2,000 frames a
second skateboarder skateboarding always
looks good in slow motion I'm noticing a
lot about this footage there's a lot of
aliasing which to me says there's no
optical low-pass filter there's also
sort of very dark areas and then very
blown out areas like the guys shirt yes
super blown out and this is just an
example of earlier high speed video
cameras had a pretty lousy dynamic range
so bright stuff blows out way sooner
dark stuff falls off way sooner so you
end up with like sort of very contrast
he looking footage still perfect to see
what's going on here the quality of
light looks like it was evening makes it
more difficult to actually get stuff
when it's in the evenings you could
definitely tell when the Sun is lower I
quite like it at shell sunny day vibe we
did a video with Tony Hawk actually in
there Dan broke his wrist I did trying
to impress and tried to do so clearly
couldn't do
this is veritasium slinky video 2
million views very cool very simple
demonstration of how when you drop a
slinky it all compresses and the bottom
doesn't move anywhere in space until
it's completely landed physics physics
cool physics we shot this video as well
yes what is so cool
some of stuff I like about shooting
things in slow motion is you get to see
things from a scientific perspective
that you wouldn't normally get to see
necessarily or it's more difficult to
perceive and it's a really good
demonstration of that veritasium is an
excellent educational channel highly
recommend it - this is a slow-mo clip of
a bird having breakfast this is great
food kind of failed video puts in his
mouth throws it away
I honestly think animals are the best
subject for slow-mo like something as
simple as that
oh that's amazing it also makes you
wonder how often animals fumble their
lunch I was once filming a be drinking
pollen from a flower and it fell out so
rolled out back because it got drunk in
slow-mo you see tons of that that clip
was probably a very short space of time
as well because birds like that small
tend to move very quickly they're very
high metabolism so that looks really
fast and judging by the snow moving in
the background is probably only a few
hundred frames a second if that may be
on a phone because it's very snowy you
got that nice flat light all around nice
and bright looking and so even on a
phone it looks good
pretty much like having a perfect
lighting situation ice bounce I think
they've got this probably a lot of
patience and maybe almost training the
birds to be able to be used to you
there's almost no chance that this is
the first time yes person has put food
in their hand they've probably done that
months before I mean everyone's seen a
birdie but no one's ever seen it they're
slow dropping his food habits so it's
very cute and you can't like make a bird
do that all right that's enough
this is sneezing in slow motion this is
actually really old video I think I saw
this about decade ago it's also really
difficult to do when someone's sneezing
it's an involuntary movement a lot of
the time it's very difficult to actually
capture that it will move forwards and
backwards
particles are actually not too difficult
in CG a way they're sort of coming out
of focus it looks very real you might as
well do it for real
I've noticed also the lip flap enos is
real there's definitely done at least
the movement I mean they wouldn't
really be any reason not to do it for
real apart from getting the cameraman
wet framerate wise it's probably an easy
thousand the the lip flat pigeon yes
love in between 500 and 2,000 fps I want
to say this was almost this was an Advil
something for like washing hands or like
Kleenex or something I don't know what
it was but it was something to do with
germs just perfect this is an Instagram
video at the Hoover Dam 7 million views
great demonstration of an updraft
so with tall buildings like skyscrapers
and you know big flat walls like a dam
the wind will here go up has nowhere
else to go and it's sort of funneled up
wasn't it I think this is so cool
because it's literally the complete
opposite of what you'd expect messes
with your head a little bit when you see
physics working the wrong way even
though it's working absolutely the
correct way this was definitely shot on
the phone someone was probably just like
I'm just gonna pour some more off here
but I do yeah look what it did with me
phone out yeah it's pretty windy I'm
let's try this what's called by this but
maybe we should take off phantom to the
Hoover Dam see what goes up see what
goes down so this is venus flytrap in
slow motion and macro in slow motion
isn't that just normal frame rate you
can see he's sort of slowed down regular
speed footage which is why it's like the
whole reason high-speed works is that
you're taking way more pictures in the
one second space because if you don't
you end up with pictures missing I mean
if I was to swipe my hand really quickly
like that and it was taking maybe 25
frames a second you get a picture here
maybe picture here in a picture here and
then that's it but with slow motion you
take hundreds or thousands and you get a
much more smooth image week actually see
what's going on it gives you more time
to take in what's happening but you
can't get a slow-motion effect with just
any DSLR if you just playback slower
than you shot but you can record a 60fps
and playback it 24 yeah as long as you
play something back slower then you shot
it it's a slow motion
this is the giant six-foot water balloon
made by us yep this was the video that
actually made our channel take off our
videos around that time again about
twenty to thirty thousand views per
video and this got a million views in a
day which back then was really a big
deal yeah I went on the news to talk
about this video currently has a hundred
and seventy seven million views which as
far as we're aware is the most viewed
slo-mo clip on YouTube it's crazy it was
me jumping on a balloon until it popped
we tried lots of different things
jumping out of a tree of all the things
that I thought would happen I didn't for
a second think that the balloon wouldn't
pop yeah I just bounced off it I
actually see me get air as like because
it's or flings me back into the air yeah
I remember I was filming this one
usually at the beginning and you kept
bouncing off of it yeah I was like no
way is unbelievable that's what's fun
about some of the things we do sometimes
we just don't expect that to happen this
was one of the early videos we filmed on
the Phantom flex which did 2500 frames a
second in HD good old camera that one
one of the few Clips where I'm actually
doing the thing yeah it's mostly me
doing the thing I thought I'd enjoy that
one if there was anything I would do
differently now I would probably jump
from much higher I would be the one
doing it Forester or you'd be doing it
yeah I think you were unavailable that
day we started filming a different day
and not managed to get exactly what we
wanted and then there's actually a lot
of fun fact about this clip at some
point it fades out and it says sometime
later I think was actually like three
weeks later because you had then gone
into the army to do something I had to
quickly finish the video because the
first time I jumped on the balloon it
popped
I'd triggered it to slightly too early
so you didn't see that everything
popping out everywhere basically there's
a reason now that I just take care of
the filming and he does however the
thing is it made it so much better
because meant that balloon got much
bigger and sure than the second time we
did it it was a six foot balloon instead
of a five foot balloon yeah but it also
got a lot bigger as well because it was
a people know so you're saying you made
it better by messing up the fear about
it
yeah mixes good beers I think there's
people doing good work out there in
slo-mo field
tons of people with access the different
equipment I think it just shows that you
don't necessarily need the world's
greatest high speed cameras to make some
genuinely interesting slow-mo footage a
lot of phone to develop a lot of good
phone stuff yen an owl only get better
as technology moves on